this program features live coverage of
an African safari and may include animal
kills and caucuses viewer discretion is
advised
good afternoon and welcome to the sunset
Safari 2.0 my name is Taylor mccurdy and
on camera with me today is Senzo and of
course we're very sorry for all the
technical glitches that we have had but
let's hope that this time it all stay up
and running for those of you that were
watching on the damn cam thank you for
putting up with my nonsense and I will
be leaving shortly to find some animals
and and let you enjoy the peace and
quiet yeah if you've never joined us and
one of these amazing and director
safaris you can chat to us you can
hashtag Safari Lab or you can also talk
to us via the YouTube chat and we look
forward to chatting to you shall we
leave sins oh I think we will leave bye
everybody bye thank you for
participating in damn camera off right
but I'm not owning out on safari today
ralpherz also arts in a bar I think he
was going to chit her to do a bit of
droning and no not droning aerial
viewing and James is on bush walk and I
think he's gonna try Reed okay done
Tandy and she's very exciting and well
speaking of James and being on bush
walkies had quite some time to move
around it's a well jump on board with
him and see if he's had any luck with
sandy
we think we may have be pretty close to
tell me right now my also apologies for
our late start today we're in the area
where she was found this morning and
we've got badasses alarm calling and we
have got go away buttons a long boring
so we're hoping one desperately that
she's just in here but it's days on
camera hello David I could you've just
seen her and ferb it is obviously
running security detail and tracking for
us so we're just gonna go around here
the balusters are up here you can see
how very very thick it is and this is
exactly where the lippert was this
morning
so Tandy our new kind of Queen I guess
and her baby Jolanda were in these
thickets today
please send through your questions of
course hashtags for life you can send us
questions also in the YouTube chat but
maybe just stay with us for another five
minutes and let's see if we don't get
lucky because if we do see her it'll be
a very brief she won't sit tight
it's the most gorgeous Sunday afternoon
beautiful autumnal temperature 28
degrees also 32 fahrenheit Andrea I
think that your comment is very valid
you say you think the cheese found us
already and is staying out of sight I
think that that is highly likely all we
want is just a quick glimpse of her so
that we can call tail him
and here you're wondering about which
birds are long holy and way is the sound
off the go away bird and this is the
chin spot fattest abnormally very good
indicators of where a predator is I must
say it's very difficult to think of a
more perfect spot to be in on a Sunday
afternoon walking free in the West
improve national park with you guys with
us and the great Herbert Rosa in front
tracking down possibly the most
beautiful kept in all the world that's
not just about throwing the aspersions
on you David I'm also happy to be with
you today
Stacy you want to know if I've ever
found handy on foot before is I think I
have I've seen on foot I haven't seen as
baby on the 40th though so
I don't know how the baby will react but
she's so used to us now you know Taylor
found him on foot today and they were
pretty relaxed like but it's a story
lovin' calling in the trees up here
that's what we're looking for and it's
how interesting you know this is exactly
where Corolla used to hang out the last
times I saw her on foot was right in
here on Craig's first walk
yeah not sure this stage
she'll be around here somewhere okay
let's go across to Ralph he had a fairly
agitated count with earlier huh I'm not
sure what he's got now good afternoon
once again everybody on the afternoon
Safari
you're watching Safari live and my name
is Ralph Kirsten and on the camera
we've got Sebastian how's it Sebastian
yes he's back from leave and well
everybody please don't forget that it is
Earth Day today so we want to remind you
the 3 R's reduce reuse recycle and get
rid of that plastic but I'll throw it in
the bun try and use it in some other way
and please don't forget as well to join
us on the hashtag Safari live on Twitter
and on the youtube lies youtube live
chat send us your questions and your
comments and join us on the largest game
Drive in the world now I'm on the track
of Hosanna the spotted cat and we're
just trying to pick up where he was lost
seen this afternoon around midday we're
in the region and but you know how these
cats are I could be lying to us next to
the road and we've driven past him
already but we are going to try and
catch up with him so I'm not too far
from where he was last seen I'm going to
try and see if we can see those signs
and follow up while I'm doing that let's
head on over to Tyler for one of those
massive land mammals now I've only been
searching for these massive land mammals
for about how many weeks now how many
weeks have I been elephant free this is
a outrageous in fact but thankfully we
have a large herd of them they all seem
to be quite spread out at the moment
however we've got a female here and a
couple of little ones too to keep us
company and guess what we are so close
to mud wallows and I'm hoping I'm really
really hoping we are going to
elephants might bar thing today it
doesn't look like they've had one
recently and doesn't actually look like
they've drank and you water at all so
and the green again lucky but first of
course if you're an elephant snacks and
they aren't just gobbling up the silver
clasp to leave trees now the poor solve
a class the leaf tree that this elephant
is feeding on at the moment really
doesn't stand a chance you can see how
they're completely dwarfed it it seems
like they've sort of snapped it in half
and now it's desperately trying to
branch out so penny and I'm now getting
boos from final control anyways she's
not eating all of them though she's
pulling a couple of branches off here
and there and nibbling on them and then
well leaving the rest and that's not
elephants do I don't typically feed on
one tree for too long and they said
decide to pull it down then they'll feed
on it for a while now obviously we very
lucky here in the vehicles the animals
are quite a bit you add to it some
individuals don't like them as much as
others and the this lot seem to be very
relaxed they don't mind us at all
Nandhini now and I mean elephant attacks
yeah I'm not particularly common and you
know we sort of get human-wildlife
conflict so for example South Africa is
not a big one but if you go into areas
like Mozambique you go into Zambia Kenya
all these countries where there aren't
many fences and the community lands
basically infringed on wildlife zones if
you will and then you will sort of find
a lot of times elephants attacking
humans but mainly it's because people
are trying to chase them away because
they're eating their crops and then they
stand up for themselves so the chances
of an elephant actually attacking anyone
regardless as to how close you got is
quite a rare and that's why this is so
important all those things I look
there's a time to tiny babies coming
down the road three little ones just you
can see no there Kim hey there come this
way please
and I'll tell we're pretty lucky
we have a very good relationship with
with us so yes if you do get too close I
suppose it depends on the situation and
I think Ralph is talking about it this
morning how it's important that we
respect wildlife and we give them space
but it's also very important that the
animals understand for instance that
they can't touch the cause that they you
know they can't do certain things either
so we try and keep this up it's a big
female she's a big test this one
photobombing everybody people try to
take screenshots of the little one you
know you would have had your turn
at some point when you were also small
oh they're so cute they're big tusks
yeah they are munching away I'm so
excited I can't believe it it's quite a
nice size hood - it's not fangs hood I
haven't seen Fang and I don't think
there's that many individuals here she's
got quite a larger for those of you have
no idea who Fang is Fang is a one of our
favourite elephants she's got a big
tusks that curves back towards her oh
lock seams oh oh look at that little one
we ran into an older sibling now I don't
think that those two little ones that we
saw were twins
spotted Sally and then they're just
keeping one another company and as
youngsters do you I mean you see it
wherever you go the little ones normally
grouped together sort of around the same
age play with one another you know they
are very hairy you can see it quite
nicely because they're backlit they're
very young still probably only two or
three months old somewhere around there
that one that's not bulldozing the other
one that's has fallen to the floor seems
to be slightly older and of course when
one elephant toppled to the ground well
how can you resist an elephant pile
there we go trying to jump on top you're
not getting up now I'm going to wrestle
you to the floor oh this is too precious
what a welcome back I'm actually quite
happy that I didn't see elephants for
such a long time it made me appreciate
you know how special it is to see them
and we were so spoilt in the mire we saw
them every single day there wasn't a day
that went by he didn't see these Ellie's
a whole sweet
now obviously the biggest question on
everybody's mind at the moment is where
did the elephants go and why did they
leave so child of the universe you've
asked the six specifically this
afternoon remember the elephants don't
hold territories so they go wherever
they want they go where the grass is
greener they go where the fruit is
you know flourishing it just depends so
they're constantly on the move they
don't want to stay in one area for too
long they don't want to if you will over
graze over browse a particular spot so
they keep going and it's quite a nice
how they rotate their paddocks not rainy
because of course these are not paddocks
as in wild animals and they got familiar
if you've got horses or any domestic
animals goats sheep cars and you don't
have a huge area you you tend to well
like I've just said create paddocks and
and rotate them around so you don't over
grazing area elephants do this naturally
a lot of the animals that don't hold
territories do this naturally so that's
what's happened these guys have come
from the south so perhaps they went down
to the sand and the sabi River and we're
feeding along the banks on all the
papyrus and other reeds and rushes that
made row down there and had a good time
but now they're coming back coming back
into this area and since what should I
get to move forward just a little bit so
we can get those little ones again I
think we might have some obstructions
with the trees was it okay still let's
go see with this little one's going that
must be mom over there so now you can
see not twins but just one of the adults
the biggest cow who I assume is the
matriarch
hello elephants and just of course
babysitting but this one now going mom
please wait I'm exhausted from pushing
and shoving my little friend around can
I please have a drink because unlike the
other elephants that have to focus on
feeding throughout the day remember they
they will feed for up to 19 hours a day
those little ones they just can play and
and they're just suckling at the moment
they will be trying to eat bits and
pieces but how much they're actually
chewing and swallowing I I highly doubt
that you know they're getting much
nutrients from there I think what will
do sends let me go up and around
it's turn around I think they may go and
maybe wanna wait I'm just gonna turn
around so that if they do you head back
to the mud wallows we'll get a nice view
of them oh how incredible is this max
piece can you repeat what you said to me
I had my earpiece turned down a little
bit lower might get a piece of volume on
to make these down oh there we go yes
Horner I agree with you I suppose this
makes up for the technical gremlins
doesn't it I think so and so you said
what a way to start the day breakfast
with elephants pretty spectacular except
the elephants are having afternoon tea
at the moment going into a early dinner
so there they all are and I think
they're enjoying this area just making
the most of the grass I've had the most
amazing elephant sighting here you may
remember it when I first got back so it
was in the first week of March I was in
almost the same spot and seems we you
see this termite mound just over here
where this little elephant is as well
defecating and urinating I was standing
up on top of that termite mound with
David and Rickson and we were surrounded
by elephants and it was so spectacular
do any of you ever remember that Bush
walk that I went on it was one of the
best bush walks I've ever had in terms
of encountering elephants so we know
this is a very popular spot for them to
feed there's a variety of things for
them to eat from the silver cluster
these that are still bearing their pods
which I'm sure a tasty right through to
all this lovely tall green grass and his
variety of types of grass species here
too and Bush willows all nice things so
it's the perfect place and a couple of
obstacles and warm I suppose a tree to
rub on if you really wanted to scratch
an itch you could do that too perfect
thank you for coming home elephants
right seen as the elephants are the
topic to start off with I'm gonna send
you to Jane's to see what his best
elephant encounter on foot
mmm wonderful to say really there have
been so many I just suddenly remembered
the very first elephant encounter I had
on foot and I was on on my own terrified
of the bush completely and this elephant
was in the thick bush but like this over
here actually and I was walking along
alone and I heard this cross this branch
crack and I had I had to go along this
road I've been given a map and I had to
complete a route I snuck along I'm
terrified and her there he was and I
could just see his backside and I
remember him turning to look at me like
this and perhaps he realized how utterly
terrified I was because he just kind of
turned back and carried on eating and I
went
and then I couldn't stop myself and I
had to have a little run for about 20
meters after that I was my very first
elephant encounter on foot alone
thankfully I'm not quite as afraid as I
was back then I was a young buck 22
years old never spent any time on foot
in the bush on the subject of the last
segment we had sandy and cub no luck
tracks around and I think that she could
easily have seen us already and be
around here there are birds shouting all
over the place now I wonder if they're
not watching these spots from their high
points walking through this long grass
and perhaps that's why you're not seeing
them anyway we will we won't I guess
alright apparently the elephants that
Taylor have wished to be in the circus I
think it does really want you as its
well trying to balance about all this
log asaurus that's in the water
well perhaps our sister busy with the
manicure maybe it's using that EE and it
has not drank any water yet this young
elephant is very much interested in the
log and the others are all walking off
they might be going towards another dam
perhaps I don't think they'd want to
drink from these puddles but I at least
thought that they would have splashed
around with it now of course anything is
interesting to a young elephant I mean
this is not as teeny and tiny as those
little fairy things that we saw hanging
around on the road but what are you
doing why are you so interested in their
log just because that's stamping in the
mud it's not very deep visible mud
wallow it's trying out fairly quickly is
something there you can see that trunk
is working overtime know what it's
smelling maybe is it looking for mud
does it just feel nice
careful you're gonna slide that's not
very even it's it's not going maybe it's
going to slip and fall like me be
careful I've done that many at times
it's standing on the smallest side
island it's got all four feet on a dry
patch at the moment just dipping its
toes and this is so curious it's amazing
to watch that crank work and in such
beautiful light as well off to the next
pole there you go picked up a little bit
of mint please don't throw it at me
perhaps this will turn into a game of
clay light I need to get my stick in
some mud it'll only be fair so amazing
so busy hi little one are you going to
throw it at us I think you're showing
off for everybody this afternoon I think
that's what's happening here this one
likes the attention
the splashing sounds are so amazing to
you you know it's not really doing
anything here careful you don't slip
they've got great 4x4 tread but well
when you're standing on your own toes
there might be a problem it's really is
just smelling everything it doesn't pull
that plant out it's smelling the mud
picking it up throwing it around a
little bit very busy see though this is
where I wish I could speak to animals
because I would love to know what's
going through this elephants mind
perhaps you have an idea and it's here
and what do you think this elephant is
doing what do you think is on its mind
hashtag Safari live let's hear your
thoughts it doesn't have to be so
realistic if you want to get creative go
for it let's have a little laugh this
afternoon mr. Parker you're convinced
that this is definitely a balancing act
it seems like that elephant wants to
pick up that stone now it's wedged in
the mud no it's not true feet on the
island one foot on the log and one foot
on a stone
maybe it's auditioning for the circus
although you wouldn't want to go to the
circus elephant let me tell you you've
got a much better life out here
very busy
Safari lives got talent you quite right
Rebecca perhaps and win with the
presenters and the rest of the team
going to be notified about Safari lads
Got Talent I know we tried to do it in
the Mara and then that just never
happened oh this is beautiful
let's see if it's going to pull up any
of that grass no it's still just
smashing the mat around now here's
something that has happened to me on
multiple occasions Kea yes I have been
sprayed with not quite water but I've
definitely had mud thrown on me before
and in the Eastern Cape that's happened
to me and then I had it happen to me
fairly recently in the Mara - with us
teenage Carr who was just having an
absolute ball
all around me she's throwing a bit of a
tantrum and we just sat there she didn't
really mean anything by she was
desperately trying to get our reaction
which we weren't going to give her we
weren't going to race away from her
terrified screaming with our hands in
the air so he just kind of sat there and
she picked up mud and they actually I'll
try and find the video there's a small
part where she does this and you can see
the mud coming towards me so she hits I
think Manu was with me on camera that
day she got my new and I which was quite
funny and I can't tell you how many dust
baths I've had from elephants deciding
to just come stand right next to the car
and have a bit of a dust bath so that
happens quite regularly in fact it's one
of the most exhilarating experiences and
I've told you this story before I think
it's amazing I'm pretty sure you would
all love it if you got to be mud bath
thing with an elephant or being dusted
fine an offender had this one guess that
was very upset about the whole
experience
I was like I'm never gonna wash my
clothes again I was like I don't just
keep these forever it was the first time
that it had happened to me everybody
else enjoyed it right off you go to roll
Foos got a beautiful view of cinema part
of feeding thanks teller and look at
that in a golden sunlight as these
Impala feed but on the silver cluster
leaf which is quite strange because
that's I don't know if any of you have
seen I think Steve was eating it at some
stage when he when he first arrived here
it makes your mouth extremely dry and
it's I think it's a bit of a purgative
so I don't know if they eating that to
try and settle their stomach a little
bit or if they actually are immune to
the purgative nature of saw the cluster
leaves but one of my mentors once said
to me when I first started out as a
guide that if you are looking for a
predator or you want to see a predator
hunting you need to wait at the prey or
be next to the price well that's exactly
what we've decided to do we've come to
Impala plains and very apt lots of
Impala here and we're trying to find
visan
that we haven't seen any sign of him as
yet so we just hanging around these
Impala for a little while and see if we
get lucky and well while we're doing
that we can just enjoy the sheer beauty
of them in this golden light they've got
some of the Ox Pickers on them and
they're all feeding as they move through
and if there is any sign of us honest
that wouldn't blows in their favour or
anything like that and they'll pick it
up and then we can pick him up so oh
it's good you can see the colors nice
and clearly they call it counter shading
from the dark to the bottom being a very
light goroh well a good question and
thanks for asking that
and Impala or mixed feeders so they will
graze and browse and that's one of the
reasons why they are so successful is
that they can feed on a very wide range
of foods they can eat grass they can eat
most leaves and they can eat leaves of
all sorts of different plants and that's
why I'm saying there that's quite
special with that silver cluster leaf
because I've eaten a few leaves of that
and it literally almost instantly draws
up all the saliva in your mouth and look
at them feeding on it there that's quite
interesting indeed I haven't seen Impala
feeding and silver cluster leaf now
there might be other people that laugh
at me say they're saying they see it all
the time but well I'm sharing my
experience with you and now I haven't
seen them feeding on that at all so that
is the terminology as sericea all the
leaves sort of bunched on them in a
group at the end of the little branches
quite happily you wouldn't see many
animals feeding on a silver clasp the
leaf where you find lots of silver clasp
the leaf as well it's normally where
there's a high and salt content in the
soil cleaning your nose cleaning them
around the mouth
very fast as well they see that I'm
wondering it's it's it's almost doing
something quite strange why she's
feeding it must be quite uncomfortable
because I would really not want to feed
on it and you know I've seen Impala also
feeding on sickle Bush quite regularly
especially when they're under the
weather you can see that they're quite
you know the ribs are sharing and we say
as humans that the sickle Bush is like
the pharmacy of the bush and I'm sure
she's doing that because of the dryness
in her mouth no way that the tone is
it's almost like you know sometimes if
my dog my basset hound if he wants a bit
of my peanut butter sandwich I give him
a little piece and then he also does a
little bit of something like that
because it's stuck to the top of his
palate and I don't do it on purpose to
watch him suffer he's just dumb he's
just a very pushy basset but look at
that very interesting
you see that's what I'm saying with them
with the sickle Bush with him being a
little bit under the weather and then
showing the ribs and everything you know
the guy and I feed on a sickle bush and
and I'm sure bless you said that was zip
they're having a sneeze up he's not
getting a cold and the Impala did have a
look as well and it sounded a bit like
an alarm call that and there the male
doing a little bit of marking this
morning I are very wrongly suggested
that Impala have pre-orbital plans but
that was in the heat of the moment it's
some they do have a lot of little glands
on the forehead and that's what he's
rubbing they're not only rubbing but
he's probably now going to attack that
bush and I'm sure he's gonna win that
fight
scenic thank you for your question as
always and I think one of the most
difficult plants for animals to digest
would be something like the euphorbias
which is full of that white latex so
euphorbias like the like we get very
commonly here is the candle of
candelabra candelabra I'm not sure how
you pronounce it a candelabra euphorbia
a lot of white light ticks and it's
quite poisonous as well as the tambuti
which is also got that white milky latex
very difficult to digest and and in
Namibia obviously you get a lot more of
those euphorbia tar plants because it's
very desert conditions and so there's
only a few animals that can actually
digest that like porcupine Oryx and Bill
Rhino those are very special animals
that obviously have some kind of enzyme
in this stomach that can neutralize that
poison but I must say that the solver
cluster leaf is definitely one of those
difficult to digest vegetable matters
and I'm sure that they doing this for a
particular reason as I was suggesting
with them eating the sickle Bush with
its pharmaceutical value that's making
them feel a little bit better almost
like a painkiller you know it's got
Ennis and a nice and anesthetic
properties in it it's got antihistamine
properties now let's watch its throat as
it's going to be good you're tight there
it comes up it comes and it starts to
reach you but it's got a little bit more
sort of difficulty in a way that it's
moving its mouth and lots of licking
lots of licking and that says to me that
it definitely is a problem with this
lava is there feeding on this maybe it's
sort of tightening up the Bailey's it's
a little bit loose so they're looking to
you know just tighten up the stomach's a
little bit
and so everyone and there's not much
happening here there's no indication of
any predators around so I'm going to
continue the search for hasanah
while I do that let's head on over to
James and see if he's been able to find
any signs of pivot as his side well
there's always something to find on
fortune the thing that we found this
time around is a perfect summer picnic
spot in a grove of gorgeous tambuti
trees nice grass underneath them says
the chances of getting bitten on the
bottom by a tick very small which is
excellent of course what was motivating
them altameyer one it's having a
delicious summer picnic now we have
circled in circled around like a truck
circling a sprayed undefined tündi we
haven't had any luck just yet and so
we're continuing along the circle just
drainage system sure I never walked
along before and it's really it's very
pretty indeed it's going to check if we
need to follow her but right away or if
we can do a little flower segment I
think we can do a little flower segment
here's a beautiful yellow flower
it is the flower of the flannel weed
it's known as a crotch shot everybody
once you try and avoid that as much as
possible
beautiful flannel weed there and it's
called a flannel weed because it feels
David like well done just like it's a
kind of plant that grows very commonly
here but on sites that are disturbs are
they disturbed by grazing or by a
footfalls of hooves and in this case
probably around la Souris feet coming
down through here what a magnificent
afternoon we find ourselves on a knee
sorry that was my brain gathering the
question you say is the latex implants
the same as the latex used by human
beings for gloves and as other such
things and it's not precisely the same I
think it's processed slightly and
certainly originally it used to be made
from plant latex in the same way that
rubbers made from plant rubber I think
that the commercially available latex
now has probably got a lot of synthetic
component in it there might be some
plant based component in it but I doubt
it comes from something like a tambuti
tree for example it would probably come
from a much more voluminous producer of
latex as it was like a euphorbia but I'm
guessing now I'm just kind of them I'm
making relatively educated guesses I
think let's continue down through here I
noticed I watched yesterday's show oh no
I didn't hit David when I bent down
there Roy I hit my own head the
microphones in the Hat sorry about that
everybody
what you would have seen if I had hit
David was a fairly substantial fist
followed by a fairly substantial forearm
coming around the front and connecting
with my bottom jaw all righty
let's hear back to Taylor very nice to
have elephants back on the reserve it
most certainly is I cannot tell you how
excited I am although hopefully you can
hear it in the sound of my voice but our
elephants of now decided they're going
to feed in the middle of this semi open
area but the grass is so tall let me
really can't see them there's actually
the bulk of the hood just behind that
big car but you wouldn't know it they're
all hard and away how tall is the grass
and feet is asking Ramadan I think it
depends some of the grass is about 3
feet or so and then there's other areas
like where the fetching grasses that's
well over 6 foot so I would say majority
of it is just under 3 feet and then
there are some sections where it's
exceptionally tall I suppose it just
depends on what type of grass species it
is not all of the grasses get too tall
for instance the Feathertop klaris
doesn't is it massive it doesn't get as
tall as the yellow Sachin grass the
panicum can get quite big quite big
quite tall as well and the need common
finger grass can grow quite tall as well
it's hard to try and point to answer I'm
not gonna get out the car and show you
now because there's elephants here the
herringbone grass doesn't get
particularly tall at catch grass is
fairly short as well so there's a
variety of different types a lot of it
is for the top loris around here
now I think if we're patient maybe in
the next 10 minutes or so the elephant's
will pop art on twin dams Road well so
please keep an eye on the damn camera
because there might be some that are
already in that area they're moving
north and we're not particularly far
from where tell Adam I reckon if I did a
gorge of a jungle call you would all
hear me on the damn cam but I'm not
going to because I'm going to terrify
the elephants so I'm quite keen to spend
the entire after
in following this hurt I know it would
have been nice to have seen lepers but
hopefully rofl and James will be able to
pull those cats out of the bag I'm going
to make the most of the sighting because
they are my favorite animal in the whole
wide world and I have not seen them for
weeks which has made me very sad but now
I'm a very happy girl come on Ellie's
and you just pick up the pace a little
they can eat quicker and just keep going
north
so they Greg might take a while though
to pop out on the next road but either
way we'll be there to catch them I'll be
there for you mmm isn't that the friends
theme song I will be there waiting for
the elephants shall we do a loop let's
see I can hear some flapping of ears
just a little way from here maybe one or
two younger Bulls tailing the herd it
could be a possibility right it's good
oh you know one of those I think there's
like a random loan and piling here too
yeah I'll show you it oh no it's not one
there's a few let me go around the
corner maybe there's just two in fact
well that would be a few there wouldn't
it
these ones are not eating silver trust
me there's three Impala hello where's
the rest of your hood that's quite
unusual don't you think very unusual to
just have the three of them I wonder why
they've separated from the bulk of a
herd but dangerous just only being the
three of them sorry apologies I took my
foot off the brake there that was not
sensor it was me I think that listening
to the elephant's feeding through the
thicket they do look a little bit wary
that that you right in front is on high
alert at the moment you can see the
perverse years before she moves out into
the next open gap just listening just
checking around looking left and right
perhaps looking up and down to making
sure that there isn't a leopard
concealed in the grass
Brent did a very nice demonstration on
safari lives yesterday afternoon and how
tall the grasses and how thick the
vegetation is and if there was a leopard
just laying lovely nying about oh you
would never see it off they go good luck
in parlor
there is one elephant I'm cookie reverse
this so we can get a view of it
my yes come and come in mud bath is it
our friend from India no this one has
got a dry trunk it's another one and
Nandini yes Impala are very good at
alerting other animals for predators
yes giving us the death stare this
little any cheeky that's the area of the
back of the car and they've got fairly
good our sights and they will snort when
startled or when they spot something
will pick up the scent of a predator and
they're most certain you'll tell
everyone else it was by cheeky air ok
let's check down this road quickly to
see if there are any more in ease
because he's going to follow the others
and disappear fairly quickly now maybe
again maybe we'll get another young bull
slowly following up the back of the herd
just keep checking and then listening
out for any breaking branches anything
along those lines that will sort of
point us in the direction of more
elephants otherwise maybe the time for
go round we'll catch them Zack no
interesting question it's I'm gonna
repeat it you've asked basically if it's
true that elephants are the only animal
that can't jump I don't think I
hippopotamus could jump I think I don't
know I don't can't say that I've ever
seen in you know what I haven't seen an
elephant lift all four feet off the
ground but I've definitely seen the
Morea they're very good at rearing
pretending to be horses when they're so
technically they're jumping up onto
their back legs so I would say no I
think elephants can jump because yeah
what would you say that's jumping if
they have to lift themselves off their
front feet sensor Rebecca I don't know
to me that's they de jumping there
all feet off the ground - Cael they know
I've never seen an elephant with all
feet or through the hippos definitely
they porpoise a lot in water then their
feet come off over the floor but of
course I've got the buoyancy to help
them and so see ya I suppose the hippo
as well that's what they always say if
you are being charged by something like
a hippo get yourself behind a big hold
on I'm breaking news County there's a
leopard at the dam can you see it was
there for the show and more elephants
will come back meet us there
we should have just spent the day there
okay we're going let me just find arts
on the rim Revere any stations near
Brits and a dam at the moment make sure
there's not an established sighting yarn
confirmed that you've seen and leopard
around the dam can we just go to reports
I'm had my radio turned down
are you unlock with anything at the
dance
popiel update you in five minutes hang
on
were patsies
okay coffee Patsy I'm just coming down
towards the Dan are dude they were just
the viewers were saying they saw it on
the damn cam can I come in join you
please
well how's that I got to doing my
favorite things
Ferrari Safari elephants are now maybe
even a leopard Patti I'm just the thing
I'm so sorry oh right we're going to
navigate our way through the zebra
crossing and the wildebeest crossing to
try and find the leopard which i think
is just up ahead but if we go to James
and the meantime well things seem to be
hotting up quite a lot at the moment we
found more tracks
so we've now headed into a slightly
different area down towards the central
area where there a couple of patterns or
two holes
Taylor's heading towards a leopard
perhaps Ralph's heading towards
delivered perhaps it's going to be 11
Walker's board or perhaps we will just
look at gymnast poriya bucks if earlier
now if ever there was a plant that
tested more bitter and nasty thermos
silver cluster leaf that Impala was
eating earlier this is it gymnast pouria
boxer folia and if you were making a
bitter salad for your worst enemy you
would put this in the salad and then you
would take this the turpentine grass and
you would crush it up over the top of
your gymnast boreal salad and you were
defeated two worst enemy and they would
be so disgusted by what you had given
them tannin mixed with turpentine
aromatic oils disgusting Deborah you're
wondering a supercluster leaves go
dormant in the winter time hmm I feel
like I've lost my mind I saw the trusty
little evergreen
I think the sulfur cluster leaf is not
an evergreen so it does go dormant
remember very few things go completely
dormant even in fact some trees same as
they do in South America will in fact
become dormant at other times of the
year when they can reduce competition
very good example is some brown ivory
trees sometimes Java Bears did and they
lose their leaves during sort of
springtime when everything else is
trying - but did you compete for
nutrients and for soil resources they
lose their leaves go dormant briefly and
then get them again when the
competitions is less always yes yes
that's correct
so the custody fees are like most of
them most of the other trees around here
the most common family of trees is the
combat combat AC and they're part of
that family obviously all the competing
trees live in the convert AC family and
so I think all of them lose their leaves
in the winter time which I guess
indicates dormancy probably not complete
dormancy but it is know dormant here is
a central road now Juna we once a very
fine example of humanity striding
towards us there he is backlit by the
Setting Sun Herbert what have you got to
tell us no track okay we'll follow you
wherever you go
so dormancy is really a it's not a day
because it doesn't get that cold here
it's not something that all things have
to do at all and I'm thinking of a tree
or it's not something that they have to
do in the winter to take time I'm
thinking of a tree that we have in the
garden in the Eastern Cape called the
fiddle wood tree and it's a South
American tree and it loses its leaves in
December it's a disaster Christmas time
loses all its leaves and then round
about now it blossoms and makes its
fruits so it's verdant green going into
the winter time and then it's it's sort
of miserable at Christmas time and
that's because where it comes from it
doesn't need to be dormant in the winter
because winter is just slightly cooler
than summer so it's not like any of the
pine trees or boreal trees trees we
found the boreal forests that must go
completely dormant Eli yes they do and
many other poisonous plants you said you
animals each tambuti leaves they do eat
tambuti leaves I'm coming through dead
oops no you're not coming through that
way
yeah II like they do eat em but she
leaves
we've got elephants that can do that
sometimes kudu can definitely black
rhino specialize in tambour tea leaves
and porcupines eat the base of tambuti
in fact that faber favored the base of
timber tea trees in their favour the
roots so yeah then for just about every
single poisonous plant out here there's
something that has evolved the ability
to eat it and we as human beings are
noticeably absent on the list of poison
tolerant creatures we can't eat em booty
if we eat any of that euphorbia stuff
the draft was talking about it's really
bad for us ah
varoom you're asking about teak and
sandalwood trees in the sabi sands now a
sandalwood no definitely we don't get
sandalwood as far as i'm aware but you
do get a tea tree
not so much here but down on the bigger
rivers like the manulito River or on the
Sand River or on the sabe River you will
find trees called the natal mahogany
which is a very similar to a teak tree
that we file or means the closest thing
we have to a teak tree out here in South
Africa and then of course in the
rainforests of Central Africa you'll
find various kinds of teak trees but I
don't think and they'll be related to
tea trees as you find in other parts of
the world of course we get a tea tree
here we get the Transvaal teak tree
actually we get two types of teak trees
we have the transport eke and we get to
the round-leaf teak now there are leaf
tea tree should be all over the place
but it never grows bigger than this and
it doesn't go bigger than that because
the elephants tear it to pieces if you
let it grow in the absence of elephants
you could grow into a tree that you
could make furniture our table and
there's one transfer our teak tree on
Juma the big one Brent and I have both
tried to climb it to get at the pods who
had a big competition in it I mean the
very first few months that we worked
here together to try and get at the pods
so there is definitely a transport teak
tree here huh forgotten that thank you
very much all right Taylor is speeding
towards the dam I imagine she must be
there I don't know she has a lipid I
don't I don't have the leopard James not
yet I'm not sure who it was maybe some
of you can help us if you did see it on
the dam cam Patsy wasn't sure who it was
however we did have ten gaana around
this area last night with Brent and nan
saw him this morning I don't think maybe
he was slinking around here apparently
husana was seen off of triple-m and and
some of the Juma guides spent a bit of
time with him earlier we didn't go there
because we're waiting for the elephant's
to come out and then we're also
entertaining you on the dam way that is
not a hole we want to be going into my
goodness we almost got sucked down I
don't even
in the behind us oh my goodness caught
me trapped
where are we gonna go how are we gonna
get through this yeah I'm trying to
sorry I'm sure we're just trying to get
out of here we are in thick vegetation
super thick vegetation now we obviously
bundu bashing off-road yeah I'm really
hoping it is gonna beating on of the
nice to see Amit anyways let's jump
aboard a Roth's car and see how close he
is to his leopard
thanks teller and while everybody I'm
really doing just a little bit of zigzag
suture because the last visual of of
this particular cat not sure quite yet
I'm going to keep it for you a surprise
for everybody he was heading in into
this block so I'm just trying now to
catch up with him and well for all
intents and purposes we might not find
him at all but we just need to keep you
know if he was moving in in one
direction and be lining it we may have
lost him but well we've just got to keep
looking at and hopefully something's
gonna pick him up give a bit of an alarm
call and that will help point us in the
right direction so it's all about now
just trying to
follow up I'm going to just stop over
here in this open area and just listen
it's very quiet not seeing anything for
now we're not hearing anything either
that's all very exciting but it could
all be very disappointing as well
because it might be that we've we've now
lost him so I think we just start up
again there's nothing happening and we
don't have a visual we don't have a
sound we've got nothing for the moment
but we know he was here that is the clue
we have and for the rest of it we just
need to be persistent and move around
from spot him if he's gone flat well
then he's an invisible cat and he's gone
and unless he gets up and moves or he
flicks his tail and we spot that little
bit of white well then he's pretty much
gone a little bit further in here I'm
wondering if you didn't go flat near to
the road our mutt double back and go
back to the road and start all over
again but I just want to hit a little
bit deeper in first and cover that side
of things and then and sorry I'm not
looking at you everybody I am now all
eyes and ears for this Leopard
to be careful we don't fall into an art
[ __ ] all Jessup's isn't something all
over there it could be stalking he could
be doing anything it could be a she I'm
not giving anything away all right well
there's lots of excitement this
afternoon and let's hope that we can
catch up with them let's head on over to
Thalia and see us her search is going
well we haven't found anything yet we've
cut through the block I'm gonna turn
around now and go back down however
think I may have to change a tire at
some point as we've done some serious
offroading I apologize I'm just gonna
keep looking for the Zipit I was we
never gonna find him and so yeah so
earlier today as i was a-sayin husana
was sitting just off triple m or
opposite the power lines in the West so
I think you're on Arethusa
or Simba Billy and the pony who is just
relaxing there but and I turned my game
driver ad off so I didn't quite know
what was actually going on so he
apparently was walking Johan who's also
trying to help us find the snippets who
he was sat with him and said that
lisanna had walked all the way down
Bella nighties Road and part of Plains
and then going west towards Triple M so
I think that's who was that side I'm
trying to figure out who would be here
Patsy said it did look like a male look
quite big and when and we know that in
Ghana was in this area and I don't know
if anybody managed to find him in the
end there were reports of two leopards
at at one point and well the proof will
be in the pudding soon won't it when we
can find one of these cats but no I
don't know where he's gone so I'm just
checking the grass is very tall and he
has vanished Yan Yan have you found
anything
your highness just yeah I'm checking
because I know these cats can be super
sneaky and just end up walking behind
you not that either of them would be
running away from us I did speak to
Patsy's he didn't seem too nervous you
walked right past the car I don't know
what type of you you guys got on the gun
of the cam cam
the Tam cam we'll keep searching I
haven't seen any tracks crossing guard
cut line yet I'm just gonna go back and
maybe see this leopard didn't perhaps
sort of hide closer towards central
maybe he didn't go too far east it's
difficult when you don't know where they
turn where exactly they went off I
trying to get there as quick as I can
I'm just gonna have a little look I feel
like I'm a meerkat not just doing as I
apologize that I'm not looking in any of
you but I do want to find this leopard
and if I keep staring at the camera I'm
gonna miss it done that a few times
that's for sure driven straight past
animals okey-dokey off you go back to a
James and hopefully the next time you
come back to me there will actually be a
leopard
I give most impressively both laugh and
Taylor think they have 10 Ghana not only
is he still in the area
but he's doubled himself that is gonna
freak Okumura art completely there's no
ways that they're the young pretenders
going to come and take over this area if
there are two King Ghana's fantastic
stuff had no idea lepers could do it but
here we are it's just you learn
something new every day as they say
brilliant we have found nothing useful
on the tündi front and that is not for
lack of effort so I'm just enjoying my
Sunday stroll here are some yellow
flowers come hither David this is look
at them Bundy Bundy or bunny Bundy bunny
dandy but Vandy bunny
Bonnie not bunny or Bundy
Bonnie who say is it could possibly be
Tandy that hopped over to the dam cam it
is possible it's sandy I think it's more
likely to be House Horner in fact I
think Ralph is probably on the trail of
husana and I think that Taylor is
probably on the trail of tuganda that's
my guess I have absolutely no reason for
really saying that other than where they
were last seen this a lovely flower a
common one that we often show you called
just Ischia flower but what is very
interesting about it is that it has been
grazed you see this now I suspect that
the culprit for this sort of trauma to
the plant was a niala and often we see
them with their heads in the grass and
people must think to themselves gosh
these presenters talk nonsense look at
that in Jana it's grazing it's not
browsing but when they preach their pute
that sort of word when they put their
heads down into the grass this is what
they're going for they're going for
these little herbaceous plants and that
dug well they don't have any wood on
them and they often have nutritious
flowers but more often than not they
also have nutritious leaves Herbert what
is the story no sign okay we'll go up
towards Central I'm afraid her but
despite the fact that he has got a
beca's porcupine quill in his ear has
decided that this direction is not going
to work for Tandy
let us go along this beautiful game path
Oh Paulie you say do I have a favorite
plant in the bush I have many because
they have different sort of meaning to
me the first and I suppose favorite
plant that I have is the loaf of milk
berry metal caramel cheetah I love it
because it's one of the first trees I
learned out here and it's a it's like a
fairy tale tree it looks like it comes
out of a Tolkien novel that's one of my
favorites then in terms of flowers I
love the smell of the gardenia the smell
of the num-num the smell of the Jasmine
big mahogany trees natal mahogany trees
gorgeous to climb and so those I suppose
would be some of my top 10 you want me
to go in here some Yanis Herbert is fond
some yellows everybody unfortunately
because his eyes are not unlike the
Hubble Space Telescope most of us can't
see them but he can see them and enjoy
them we just have to take his word for
it most of the time I'm sure he will get
us into a position I'm sure the Sun
quickly that is very beautiful there is
it the Sun is beginning at Sunday
setting and soon the night will come
okay
continue along here I do hope that one
of those lipids appears you know deeply
Exim the way so often when there are
prospects like that to leopards have
been seen and yet we sometimes just
don't manage to get in their way favor
do you know what plant this is I don't
know that I've seen this plant here
before have I I think that this David
believe it or not is the map Ani
pomegranate yes I just
I think anything I say Haley's war there
I meant to say I kid you not and I
nearly said something else but it makes
beautiful yellow flowers I would like
some confirmation on this I haven't seen
one of these trees for a long time I'm a
Pawnee pomegranate please there Judy H
if you're watching on the Sunday
afternoon can you confirm them a Pawnee
pomegranate I think that's what it is
well what's its latin name something Moz
ambi kiuic Mazembe cim something
Mozambique um I think that's what it is
it's not particularly attractive now but
when it gets its flowers just stunning
I'm just got interesting really
escalating like I may seem that a very
tree before not many parts of this
reserve after three years that I haven't
at some stage rather driven past or
walked over Riga Zambezi akin thank you
very much
rise Ogham Zambezi a command pretty sure
that that's worth what that was there we
go that came through from the final
control I'm not sure entirely who looked
it up Sean your didn't have lavender
grows there but it certainly does my
mother's garden I'm not sure if it
doesn't go naturally here no I mean
lavender is a think a European herb and
so it doesn't grow over here and
certainly doesn't grow in great fields
like it doesn't the rule bucolic
settings of Italy or France or research
hello Aidan aged seven you want to know
if I ever sleep outside you can but you
have to sleep up in a tree so if you
wanted to sleep outside you'd find a
tree like this one and you'd put a
hammock in the tree or you would put a
tree house up there and then you could
sleep there otherwise if you want to
sleep outside what you have to do is
build a fire and then you have to have
lots of people you can't just sleep on
your own outside over here because
hyenas will come quite often and lions
will come quite often and so somebody
has to stay awake the whole night and
keep a lookout for what's going on
otherwise you could can be very
dangerous so no we don't sleep outside
but you can if you're very careful and
if you have a watch okay good let's go
back across to Ralph and see if he has
found or see which version of kangana
he's found
yeah yes well we haven't found anything
as yet everybody so we're still hot on
the trail but no sign of him just yet
and simple we're going into some rough
terrain here so we're just making all
taking all precautions and I'm going to
be Haiti just to the road now and I'm
gonna make like we said we're gonna make
this circle bigger and we're gonna see
if we can pick up on some checks daddy's
come out to block because I'm not going
to just now bundle bash through this
thick stuff until infinitum so this is
the last little chick and then we got
out onto the road and see if we can find
some tracks on that side it's very
strange that he's so giving us the slip
now minimu that's a very good question
it's mostly to do with the heavy tent
and that's the reason why lipids live
here because it's very dense and quite
thick vegetation you know generally
speaking you know not always generally
speaking cheetah don't particularly do
that well in in this kind of thick
vegetation they can do however I've seen
them doing very well in thick vegetation
but the major reason I think is because
of the concentration of lipid here and
so if the cheetah move in and they start
to hunt these lipids walk around during
the day and I think these cheetah will
get their food stolen from them
pretty much every time so they're going
to be wasting all that energy and
eventually will die from exhaustion
because they're going to spend expend
all that energy chasing animals down and
then just to have it stolen and if they
do that three or four times they can
literally die as quick as a few days so
I think that's the reason because of the
concentration of leopard in this
particular area but there are areas
within the cougar National Park where
the cheetah do very well and I think
that's where the concentration of lipid
is less
so and yeah in the Maasai Mara as well
with this very high concentration of of
lipid and lion and they they seem to
stay away from the triangle the Mora
triangle and they're all on the other
side of the river where it's very much
more open and not that much place for
leopard to hide there are a lot of lion
there but not as much quite as
concentrated on the more a triangle side
so that's where it makes a lot of sense
to me that that that theory then rings
true we still now you know that's very
frustrating sometimes you'll almost not
even want to know that there's a leopard
around here because if you know that
there's one around and you can't find
him it's worse than knowing that there
is one in you can't give thanks for your
question they definitely is a hierarchy
around predators because look at the
lion the biggest and the strongest of
all of them he will and they will the
females and the males if they can get
ahold of any of the other predators and
they will killed him and still they prey
as well so the Lions generally rule the
roost amongst Peters the leopards get
away with it because they're very wily
and they can also go up the trees and
that's immediately what they do and they
get a kill and where is cheetah they
tried to get around it by hunting during
the day and then and finishing their
food as quickly as possible so they they
they eat very quickly everything looks
like a leopard at this stage just
spotting something over there so the
cheetah eat very quickly no it's just a
couple of logs and a little bit of a
brown for any color at the bottom sheet
very quickly in the hope that they will
have finished the the food by the time
any of the Predators arrive but they
still they need to eat extremely quickly
and so as I say the cheetah she does the
probably the most vulnerable of all of
those of all those predators
now everybody I'm gonna continue see if
I can pick up the checks of the
slippered while I do that let's see John
over to James with a tiny little
predator and I ain't so tiny it's about
the same size as my hand I don't know
why I'm talking like that it is of
course a golden orb spider ha hang on a
second
David there's something really
interesting going on here whether we
have caught them in flagrante delicto
if you come slowly around the sway and
look underneath her there is a male
you've got him well that male everybody
is in the process of doing what many
many golden or web spider males try to
do and fail resulting in their own
demise errs isn't that fantastic
he's mating good Anya son well done now
I read about these things yesterday and
it is quite astounding what happens I've
never seen this before and the details
of what's going on there are going to be
almost impossible for us to see in I
suspect the fact that she's moved has
probably disturbed and exactly where he
was making his deposit so what he does
is he deposits his sperm into her using
his pedipalps now his pedipalps a sort
of mouth parts that are in the front
unsurprisingly of his mouth so there
aren't here and he does that by the
first thing he has to do is he's got to
get the sperm into these little like
sort of suction things they're described
as being like the libs of a fountain pen
so an old-school fountain pen used to
dip in the ink that's exactly what his
pedipalps like but he's got to get the
sperm into those things from his what
they could go nate'll Sakon his go
nettle sack he's underneath in a knot in
a place where he can reach it with his
pedipalps and so he has to lay or not
lay he has to weave a small silken sort
of cup then he makes his deposit into
the cup and then he dips his pedipalps
into it and then with the pedipalps full
of his sperm he must go and find the
female
and then do the dance and eventually
climb on top of her and place there's
pedipalps in exactly the right spot and
what's interesting is that no two
spiders pedipalps or no two different
species of spiders have pedipalps that
can fit to the sexual organs of a female
and s they're the same species if that
makes sense I've said in very roundabout
way which means it's a lock-and-key
mechanism so only the pedipalps of that
male will fit into the sexual organs of
the female so if another male spider was
to come along here he would have no luck
at all isn't that amazing
Ali you say why's a female so tiny in
the mail so big
well the male's doesn't need to be big
eats got no real purpose other than to
be a depositor of sperm she's so big
because the bigger she is the more eggs
she can lay and apparently it's really
the number of eggs are able to lay as
directly proportional to the size that
they're able to attack attain whereas
for the male's of course who doesn't
really make a big difference now he's
hanging on there for dear life Kathy you
say is she going to kill him now she may
well but we can rest assured Kathy that
he's going to die the happiest spider on
planet Earth this evening he's just
watched a gorgeous sunset he has just
had a wonderful time with his consort
and well his purpose as a species Award
as an individual he's served he has done
what evolution made him to do and so he
can die satisfied that his role on
planet Earth has been satisfied very
nice sort of way to close out your life
really I would think she of course will
lay her eggs somewhere in a tree she
will fold some leaves together bind them
together with silk lay the eggs inside
there and then she'll drop onto the
floor and die their annual spiders so
they don't make it more than one year
Kiryu wondering how many eggs she'll
have in a sec I've read you know there
are lots of different golden orb web
species and in fact they occur in
different parts of the world they occur
in Europe Africa Australia which means I
must occur in Asia as well I've read
between 300 and up to 3,000 eggs and in
fact somebody got so specific that they
said they lay 384 eggs per egg sack that
was an Australian species so I imagine
this one is probably slightly different
from that imagine your job as a
researcher at university was to count
golden orb web spider eggs I feel that
you would not be as satisfied that your
purpose had been served as much as that
male spider even though he might just be
about to sacrifice himself you see me
yonder now if he knows he's going to die
will its ask him Harold Harold are you
aware that you might die no no he's not
he says he says very clearly that he is
not going to die that he's very happy
where he is and in fact he's unable to
speak because his his ecstasy is so
complete you Sonny I promise you that he
has absolutely no idea he's going to die
I don't think he has any concept of what
death is frankly I think they're a few
species that have any idea of what death
is Oh Robert you say what's the success
rate of the eggs hatching are probably
less than 1% I'm gonna say Robert you
know so hatch were not hatching they're
probably you probably find out 80% of
them hatch but you'll find that 1% if
not fewer make it to actual adulthood
and it's what we call our selection and
animals like this in fact lots of
organisms like this that allow multiple
clutches of eggs that then realize there
few will make it to adulthood so they
you know they just lay far far more than
would be required to sort of satiate a
population because they know so if you
will survive and then the opposite end
of the scale is us which is case
selection if I remember correctly and
that means that we have very few
offspring but we invest a whole lot more
in parental care and you probably find
that for the same amount of energy you
probably have the same number of
offspring that survive to adulthood okay
now I don't know if the Tooting garner
hunters have managed to find anything
Ghana but it's getting dark now so we
got to head towards the road we will
catch up with you a little later we're
trying we are trying we've come back
into this block again because I've done
a full loop and I've seen no tracks at
all coming out and we're just being
careful because my goodness the amount
of Porcupine Warren's that are here and
aardvark burrows we've already fallen
into one sorry brain mire two broken
rusty oh hang on your hands calling me
throw your hand
oh I'm coming quickly thank you very
much I'll be there shortly
okay let's trap all of the street uh
whoa I think Yan has found something
amazing okay I'll be there shortly so
just keep coming and east on central
hold on since all just try to get out of
here quickly very very thick I'm just
trying to make up some time your hands
said then partner gave away the presence
of the snippet I don't know who it is
we're gonna find out we're gonna find
out shortly
Nene wants it to be Singhania I love
watching him and it's nice to see him
onions old true for game we're not far
from the road navigate through a couple
of little things yeah I do apologize
I'll give you all my attention in two
seconds I just don't want to fall into a
hole we're almost there I think your
hadn't came out this route so I'm just
following basically where the grass has
been but I don't want to turn my head
away for a second
because I know what will happen here's
the road
let's jump on 4x4 you don't need that
anymore okay
that's up the game I know what that this
area is like off of central it's
exceptionally thick super super super
thick so we'll just make up for a bit of
time here we're not far
wonder if it was these Impala in here
some Rams know how next she said to me
he said they used moving arts he's gonna
have sundown as I think and you didn't
think we're gonna have much lecture and
said he was gonna go and check central
on his way out just in case I think
what's happened is he's come through
here whoever it is snuck around and then
slipped on the sway I don't know how far
down st. really is we're just going to
go through giraffe dip pretty quickly
whoo right so these votes could either
be a globally viral voting Tandy turn
Ghana or husana well I know it's not was
he was Inland Revenue's non-coffee I'm
coming up thank you I didn't even see
you in your hand is he behind that way
okay a top there okay let's see if we
can see from here it's just quickly look
maybe there's a gap who could be either
it could be Tandy I can copy I'm gonna
stand by and see if I can get a view yes
I think of like visual no that's a stick
I don't have visual confirm did you see
the leopard hmm okay so it's moving some
way through yeah I don't know way at the
moment so I know husana was seen in the
and the waist I'm just checking
carefully maybe we can scan here soon
some of you can hold
this is Anita Sunbird shopping not in
our direction
you know you know as if it's moving
quite a bit could be sandy
maybe I don't think it was a sauna like
I said I had behind or Brienne Tex and
try and call me into the siting a little
bit earlier go again this is something
trying to see if anything's going to
shot and give away the prison looking
for
you just having looked nothing maybe I
don't know mystery yeah well now they
saying maybe it was a sauna oh maybe we
were fed wrong information you can hear
the crested Franklin's are calling but
they're not alarming I don't know I'll
be happy for any leopards Oh bless you
since I was doing a good old sneeze I
scouted Ralph and see if he's managed to
pull one of those spotted cats out of
the bushes because they've been hiding
away from us today
no spotted cat just yet no such luck
everybody I am still on the search on
the lookout and now we're basically just
doing the big circles because we lost
him in the secrets day we didn't see him
and I'm hoping that these guys haven't
sent me on a wild-goose chase because I
haven't been able to see any tracks I do
know that that there was a leopard
around this particular area earlier
poorly good question the best the easier
of the two outside is more so in green
grass when it's very green because the
leopard has got that more phony color to
him so or herb so in winter when
everything is brown they're all a little
bit better camouflaged but nonetheless
it's it's slightly easier I would say in
green grass but it's still not easy if
they don't rise that little tip of the
tail which is like a little white flag
that a lot of us use as a telltale sign
and let the pan do spot them and then
it's very difficult to actually find
them as you're driving along so you're
using all the clues you've got to look
for the tracks if they've crossed
through a block and then crossed at the
road but once again if you if you're
driving along trying to cover a big area
you can very easily miss that little
check that goes across the road and then
you're straight past so sometimes it's a
little bit of luck that you just need to
get and hopefully pops out and walks
along the road then obviously we just
need to drive up behind him and then
you're spotting quite easily but once
they're in the thick stuff you need to
really almost just get very lucky that's
at the end of the day but at this time
of the evening the Sun is just busy
shaking it's that sort of golden hue the
golden hour
golden two hours this is the time when
very often lions and leopard will be on
the move walking
marking the territories and so we've got
a good opportunity now of finding these
cats on the road at least we know we're
in the area but as I say it's almost now
luck of the draw
we've just got to keep on and zig
zagging I'm going to go down we're on
via Taylor access which is the main road
coming in from the Juma gate and almost
straight to camp so this is sort of a
very central road and they were they
were seen just to our south so I'm just
trying to assume that there maybe cut
through this block and land up on the
road if they not then they may be
heading back onto hello I'm just hearing
some guinea fowl just stop and listen so
their time of the evening when guinea
fowl can call anyway because they're
gonna go up and start roosting so
they're all starting together but they
starting that continue a little bit
sometimes as I say you've got all the
suspense and then it all comes to nought
but that's the bush we can't you know
we're not we're not going up to a window
and is the leopard waiting for us this
is totally wild totally live and we're
trying our best to to get these animals
but it's not always possible we do try
and use our skills to the max but well
the animals do remain elusive and as
much as they're hurt or habituated to
the vehicle
Syd made the good point that we may have
driven right past one of these cats and
they don't even give up out of the grass
that's that's the one downside of them
being so used to vehicles and people
they don't really get a fright and so
you know normally if you drive through
the bush like that if the leopard was
there and they weren't really a bit you
I took two vehicles they would jump up
or move out the way and then that's when
you spot them was with
that movement but with them being so
relaxed that could be sleeping literally
two three meters away from where you
drive past him and you won't even see
them might just be on a wild goose chase
yeah but if we see anything interesting
along the way we will stop and see what
we can see that's what's nice you
sometimes have that goal but you know
you might have an elephant chasing a
lion or something in between
it's always interesting what is the bush
can assert us that's always what is so
exciting about it
well exactly thanks Bix in FC saying
hopefully not plastic let's not get any
plastic thrown around I saw a wonderful
initiative in Port Alfred er one of our
local supermarket chains they they were
actually taking ten plastic bags if you
came in with ten plastic bags and and
brought them in which they were gonna
then used recycle they would give you a
brown reusable paper bag and so they
started doing that now bringing getting
everybody to bring in their plastic bags
and well you know what everyone I surf a
lot on our East Coast which is the
Indian Ocean and we've got a river
coming in just where where we love it's
called the Cowie River and the amount of
pollution that starts to come down the
river you know we have a lot of wind on
the coast and so plastic bags get blown
into the river and it all washes out
into the ocean and we see a lot of
pollution while we surfing you know it's
probably better than most places in the
world but eventually that washes up on
the beaches it suffocates all the sea
urchins the Turtles you know get stuck
on them as well and they also suffocate
and it's it's just so sad especially
most people don't actually see that
suffering from from something as simple
as buying a plastic bag and you throw it
in the bin or it blows out your car
window or you know it's just we all need
to make a collective change as human
beings even just those small little
change you know if today you don't pass
three plastic bags you get a brown paper
bag well you know what those three
plastic bags aren't gonna land up in the
landfill site or in the in the in the
rivers or wherever and you can make a
change like the old African proverb goes
if if you think you smart too small to
make a difference well try spending an
evening in in your bed with a mosquito
in the room
ha ha think about that one that little
mosquito will keep you up all night and
he's but a little smidgen of of a of an
organism so don't think that you're too
small to make a difference everybody can
make a difference and well it's let's
all try together on this earth day just
to remember about what we are doing and
how we can maybe change that's all just
the thought that counts to start and
then you know that can grow that can
become a movement
well the movement I have is for the
moment trying to find Leopard but it's
been the whole afternoon now sometimes
it's it's best not to try and find him
and then it's a lense up that you did
well while I continue on the search it's
head on over to Taylor he's also doing
the same I I fear there is much Bush
broken telephone that some pets around
at the moment the conflicting stories
that were being told on the radio were
magnificent so now we actually don't
know who this could be
who was on Triple Aim all those have to
wait and see let's see if we can find a
leopard zone between us oh there we go
so the tally is in and 56% of you are
hoping that it's going to be tündi
wouldn't that be nice I I'm hoping I
really wanted to beat Singhania because
I think it's quite cool that he's
lingered back onto the property again
after spending so much time many chat
rooms like the hospital I mean he could
recover I have yet to hear tin gana saw
for a very long time and we know that
he's oh he used to be a very vocal cat
when he was separately quite dominant
I'm just trying to see you hear these to
be some roads that would go down into
the strain inch but it's obviously
overgrown quite a lot I've never heard
horse on a saw and at all I think that's
the one I'm looking for in fact so
sandy also can be quite vocal too so I
mean it could be it could be anyone but
it would be nice to see don't you think
Dingaan are just creeping on you know
maybe coming back for a second fight
perhaps he's got strength again we'll
just go down into this little dip yeah
just gonna quickly keep checking big
little bit bumpy and just see if I can't
see any tracks in the sand maybe we just
get one please can I come and join you
up and trying to relocate how far along
central you have you reached hyena Road
yet okay hold on the things on the
leopard has popped out again
Reservoir Road what's that
okay copy I'm just on twin Dan's
approach Shane jumping back on to turn
downs heading towards chili pan if I can
come and join you there to be great I
think it's the same lipid okay
right she's the snippet is on the road
you know
Bufoni safari we're not gonna go too
fast but I want to try and play catch-up
because now we're far away now we're on
the other side of the drainage line
which is no good this is the only time
please don't let there be an elephant
roadblock please don't let there be an
elephant roadblock okay we're going down
into a little duck no we're gonna pop up
at chili pan you know you have to make
racing car sounds as well Drive
relatively quickly in the bush that's
just one of the rules now it's my
favorite thing I wish this pedometer
action you would because the speed at
which we're going is not actually that
quickly but because the roads are quiet
windy it feels fun you like little zippy
car and so it's awesome and so I suppose
the closest I'm ever gonna get you being
a rally car driver hurt so better make
the most of it
only with wild dogs do we zum-zum
zum-zum
going through little dippy up weekend so
we're not far from jumping onto vultures
nest with pups out on just central see
this is cool
very winding
okay just gonna keep an eye out though
because there could be anybody else any
other day puts tube right James I'm sure
is hoping for his knight in shining
garments to come and rescue him let's go
and see where they are and how they're
faring my two knights in shining shining
armor have got lost they are nowhere
near where we hoped there would be
anyway so we're going to look at this
tree and of course this is a good
opportunity for me to mention Earth Day
I believe Ralph's been doing a good job
of that and very worthy cause this year
of the reduction of plastic pollution
every single day we are assailed our
senses are assailed with dreadful
pictures of animals dying of plastic
pollution of huge swathes of ocean
wilderness covered in the waste that we
as human beings make on a daily basis so
if you can reduce your plastic
consumption and I bet you can then
please do that'll be marvelous thank you
very much that's the lab say about Earth
Day anyway we can look at this tree this
is Central Road that we're on now this
was the road that we told those dear
people to come and fetch us on but less
well not any luck so what we'll probably
have to do is create a fort underneath
this tree and sleep inside it right
we're we're going to care we're not
really adding going to sleep and fort
there will probably will be picked up
let's go back across the Ralph who I
think is still looking for the invisible
Leopard
looking for a lipid we are everybody and
well once again if you're struggling to
find your predecessor go to the pray so
we're back with these Impala that are
still in the exact same spot and well at
least it's something for us to watch and
chat about as well as we sit and listen
if we can hear any alarm calls and that
will give away that these lipids are
moving through the area and after we've
done that we'll continue along and see
if we can find them walking along the
road but I think we're also switching to
infrared which is our nighttime vision
shortly and just so that you know okay
here it goes you're gonna see a change
there we are so that's wonderful now
everything is on the go there
then these Impala quite energetically at
this very moment in time and so now you
can see everything without us having to
use any lights which does disturb them
and we don't like to do that with
daytime or die urn or animals little bit
of odd you body there huh yes see that
that's also a bit of starting a bit of
head-butting females what's happening
now a bit of dominance going on that's a
young male there I think he's gonna get
sorted out by the big male if he gets
seen doing that and that's when they
start getting pushed out and forming the
own little bachelor heads because that
made the big male won't tolerate that
Kyah we have all sorts of different
antelope in South Africa we have water
buck and bush buck and aurochs and
spring back and all other ones too we've
got some kudu and then we've got some
little ones like the little Dacres and
the blue day care is one of the smallest
antelope that you find and a little
Steinbach which is an Afrikaans word
which literally translates to a stone
stone antelope and because very often
when you see them they just freeze
they're very similar color to that of
the Impala but much smaller and then I'd
stay in big herds like this Impala do
and they only normally in one or two of
them so much smaller and they just a
little thickets and a thick bush but
thanks for your question Kayla and I
hope that answered your question we've
got lots of different antelope in South
Africa but none more elegant and
beautiful than the Impala I would say
look at that everybody now starting to
get quite energetic but remember that
they need to really try and keep very
alert through the darkness hours and
it's obviously we've got the infrared or
the night vision on at the moment so
that we don't disturb them with a lot
but the vision is going to now go a
slightly less and less and that's when
the Predators really have a big
advantage when hunted not because
they're contacting by surprise but how
do they Impala combat that they've got
lots of eyes and ears and they are very
alert and anybody picks up the smell or
a sound or a slight movement in the
bushes
they will alarm call and all the rest of
them will pick that up and
run off and then normally bombshells so
they're all run in different directions
so it's difficult for the predator to
then pick up one particular animal and
also it's like me when I go surfing in
the ocean where there's lots of sharks I
always make sure I've got a friend or
two with me and then the odds are better
that if if one of us is going to get
taken while I've got a one in three
chance that it's not gonna be me so
that's why you know I take friends well
I call them friends but it's just making
up the numbers never too late thanks for
your question yes they can definitely be
another population of species in the
bush and normally if it was in natural
populations without any boundaries and I
will be able to move or migrate to
different areas when there was an
overpopulation in that we we didn't have
boundaries and countries where we put up
these massive fences and boundaries for
animals they would the the animals that
would be the surplus would start to move
out and start to populate areas where
there were less of them but now that
we've got fences around them sometimes
we do need to control those bigger herds
of of especially the bigger mega animals
like elephants and so on it is a
controversial subject because how do you
control them and like for instance in
the in the Chobe area of botswana
they've taken on a know sort of
aggressive stance on controlling the
numbers there and they've probably got
tens of thousands too many elephant at
the moment and if you if you ever get
the lucky chance to be able to go to
chair be at this particular moment in
time
it is very barren you've got trees and
dust and so it does start to have an
effect on a lot of the other animals if
you have over populations that's just
one example of other population I've
seen it in the pan goli area of
kwazulu-natal with his overpopulation of
warthogs and it's literally herds of
water I've seen hundreds of war talk out
on the plane and they they over graze
the grass to very similar like what the
elephants do but on a smaller scale so
very important and very difficult and
also very controversial ok I'm going to
see if we can continue and find some
more checks of these leopards and while
I do that I think Taylor's doing the
same let's go to her and you know what
Ralph you know probably saw a tree seen
as though we're briefly you know on the
same reserves not at the same time but
it Korea you may have remembered seeing
all those massive they look like crop
circles and but they were in fact made
by the war toys from over grazing -
there was a big problem and down on one
of those reserves and now we're having a
good laugh can I just tell you about the
leopard saga this evening so on the
radio
obviously raced because I heard there
was and leopard on Central going east
which is exactly where Johan had that
brief visual of that leopard slinking
down into the dip on Central just
offroad going in sort of a tumbler G
thicket going east would you believe
that there were two different leopards
within 20 minutes apart of one another
both going east on the only two central
roads in the northern suburbs and how's
that for a coincidence so the other
leopard is apparently on torchwood so
now we need to figure out what leopard
is moving around on torchwood and that
could be another one I'm wondering if
that is also and if that's maybe not
tündi I don't know I think Reservoir
Road because I was like where's
Reservoir Road that's not on Juma and
then that's what we asked and we're like
oh is this a torch where are you and
then we figured out was not not yet so
we Johannes racing to that sighting to
go and have a look for us because he's
also trying to hold has solved the saga
bumped into James and the bush walk team
standing in the dark because Kirsten and
Louise are now trying to find James and
they're not in a difficult spot but they
also don't know the roads very well I
mean they don't they don't get to drive
the vehicles around like we
so I was having a chuckle at the two of
them in trying to now find James but
well I suppose they're okay that'll be
alright I'm just quickly having a quick
scan yeah so now we don't actually know
what on earth is going on
which snippet is which away they are
they could be anywhere at the moment and
Ralph and I can't find any of them which
I find pretty hilarious as the nature
just have the most amazing sense of
humor a teasing us I mean like ralph was
saying he can't even find a track
neither can i and I am not seeing a
single footprint of a leopard around you
but two different people have now seen
this cat except us we just keep missing
it okay we're gonna try to dance again
and then if we can't find anything ham
art and for the just to give you an idea
of where this lipid went do you remember
that one time I think I've said do you
remember that one time about 700 tons
today when I found the in Karuma Prada
had to go it's like very far off road I
think we may have even had an awesome
McNees flying off trying to think what
bird we had nesting I think it might
have been African and a Greenwood rupees
in fact in a dead laid wood and we drove
from central just after giraffe that
when we went back towards the Milwaukee
and is that a chubby nyan you can have a
look at the char medium while I tell you
the story no communion I'm gonna take
that off we're also an infrared now as
you can see and so basically it's down
in that drainage line remember I think
it took me about 20 minutes to off-road
a space of maybe a hundred and fifty
meters it was so thick but eventually we
found the in goomars all laying out in
the open it was during the peak of the
drought it was a very long time ago may
even actually have been in 2016 right at
the beginning of 2017 but I think maybe
2016 but here we go
a beautiful flat Nick chameleon just
sitting a bath going what on earth are
you staring at have you spotted me I
wonder if it's realized that do we have
spotted it's not looking at us it's
looking down
with one eye now it's looking at us and
Oh communion if I wave at you
no wave didn't notice me what doesn't
seem to show that it noticed me that's
nice though always nice to see
chameleons and it is a very very warm
evening so I'm not surprised and I don't
think this will be the only one I think
we may see a couple tonight I think
Ralph will probably find a few as well
on his venture home he's gonna go past
some serious hot spots so there we go
Ralph shall we try and show the viewers
how many chameleons we can find tonight
not a competition but a joint
competition I'm trying to think what is
the most we've seen live in one evening
Safari you're gonna have to help me
you're gonna have to hash tags fire dive
let us know because I can't remember and
I think it's about four or five let's
see if we can perhaps beats it how much
time do we have left
29 minutes to try and beat it well in
that case then we better get a move on
here sends on I think so
I mean we should definitely get a move
on and see if we can find any more
Bobby you're asking about spikes on the
underside of its body on its baby I
don't think the comedians have spikes on
their on their Bailey they fairly smooth
they've got sparks sort of ridges going
down these their spine and but I can't
even think on the underside of their
body on their baby I don't I can't ever
remember some we just had two left find
another one now to try and have a look
and I suppose that's just the design of
it I'm not sure if it would protect them
very much I mean they're not super
prominent but like a thorn on a tree
really perhaps it enhances camouflage
breaking a sort of solid shape those
ridges up against the tree you're not
making look like a solid thing maybe
making it look more like a spiky spike I
don't know but I can't say I've ever
seen a convenient can you imagine a
standard Bailey chameleon mossy no I
don't know the chameleons yeah let's go
about they their fingers I don't know if
you could call them fingers no of course
I'm doing this because they've got to
they like that and then they just go
across let me find another one I'm
pretty sure we'll find some more yet
there it's such a beautiful evening and
really is a great app so they've got two
of those on either side that they just
sort of hook round things is it two or
three no I'm pretty sure it's tuned on
now I want to go back to that comedian
but I also want to find more because I'm
now set a challenge for myself and for
elf if he wants to partake he doesn't
have to of course nothing is compulsory
aren't you just a bit of fun and um now
we need to have a look and see if we can
find another one they've got amazing
crook for though the way that they can
hold on I don't know what they closed
what are the technical terms feet I
don't know but I don't know if I would
call them fingers right it's going to
see if ralpherz managed to find a
chameleon and perhaps he knows what
those looking pores are called
thanks Tyler well you know what I'm
talking about these two fine chameleons
but you know Tyler's got very good
chameleon eyes because when we were in
the Masai Mara she also managed to find
one out of the blue and I was driving
with behind her one morning as well so
soon she's quite good at that I used to
be very good at finding the Namaqua
chameleon
in the Namib Desert but I know what the
tracks look like and I know where they
used to hide and but I used to track
them down
here it's almost it's a little bit
random where you've just got to look in
the trees and then have good eyes to
spot them but my technique
there were thousand American aliens
which is over 10 years of tracking them
different to what we have to do here and
those are terrestrial and not
terrestrial oh okay let's head back to
Tyler she's got something lovely to show
you look at what we've got sorry Ralph
I've stolen everybody away from you but
we've got a little pill spotted outlet
and it is absolutely precious no it is
sitting so close to us maybe only about
15 meters away I can't believe it didn't
fly away it looks like it has had about
37 energy drinks so it cannot keep its
head still see Upjohn it's kind of like
me when I was trying to find that
leopard Wolf Road now the reason why I
know it's a little pill spotted eyelid
if it turns its head all the way around
I see we're gonna sear it Vance mmm
follow it it had little black spots on
the back of its head it's also got tiny
little white spots on the front on top
of its head did see I don't think it
would have gone too far little ow
little ow where did you go
it's something now I'm looking for a
nice perch if I was an hour we would I
sit probably on a tree no I think we may
have lost it may have just gone in a
little button with all the foliage being
very very well thick at the moment it'll
be quite tough tough to try and find it
again but you never know
nice spotting since we're on a roll
today aren't you please [ __ ] me a
leopard sensor I'll spot the comedians
but if you can find the late but for me
that'd be great okay I'll check let us
let us now find another jhemini on we
can have another look at it this has
been a hysterical day hasn't it I don't
know about you I think you would prefer
to have actually seen earlier but Ralph
and I promise you are trying our
absolute best absolute best now I very
rudely interrupted Ralph I'm sorry Ralph
so let's go back to him to find out more
about that Mara chameleon thank Stella
and to answer that question I think if
I'm not mistaken chameleons are by deque
Tillis because they've only got two
fingers on each foot or each arm so I
think it's bard activist if that's if
I'm not mistaken and very very
characteristic track that they leave
it's actually it can only be confused
with a tortoise or Terrapin track
because of that scrape that they do but
obviously the body of them of a
chameleon a much thinner than than the
shower or the body of a tortoise so the
the the feet would be much closer
together so you wouldn't be able to
mistake it for that but they do put
their foot down and then they drag it
forward so you have that sand exactly
the same with the tortoise so in soft
sand and a little baby tortoise you
could confuse it with them with
chameleons and I've actually done that
before
and I've been tracking for many years
when I did that so very easy to make
Ravinder how many species of chameleons
are in the reserve let's just put the IR
on there and see if we can spot that
there we go
trust the old favorite I think that only
the the what is it
I forget the the the the flat flat
nicked chameleon and I think this and
one more but there's not many but
definitely the flap nicked chameleon
very common and we get down south on the
Eastern Cape we get the little dwarf
chameleons they tiny little things less
than the size of your finger and that
includes the tail so here we have a cape
scrub here one of the usual suspects
that are the first of the nocturnal
animals to be out and about this could
fall prey to animals like caracal and
jackal and remember now we've turned off
the lights so he's not confused by
anything anymore and he can continue on
his normal behavior look at those ears
ever listening out a and very big eyes
to enable him to trap any light that
they might be but most be operating by
sound and by smell very good sense of
smell as well very fast are these little
chaps and there are quite territorial as
well you'll see them sometimes the guide
mock on top of a little termite mound
it's actually one of the checks in signs
that we had on one of our assessments
and I got it wrong a couple of times but
I'll never get it wrong again it's some
special little mark that they leave very
impressive you're watching something in
there all of that was just relaxing but
okay I think we need to continue because
I want to see if there's anything else
wonderful that we can find sorry if I
started there but Bailey said
you assumed out okay so let's continue
and see what other nocturnal creatures
we can find speaking of that Taylor
still got some of those nocturnal
creatures let's go off here I'm hoping
sir I'm still searching for chameleons
I've got my heart set on time trying to
find as many as I can not winning though
now Jade I have a note about this I just
need to find it because I cannot
remember for the life of me I've had way
too much energy today
I shall read it to you in a minute I
just want to go through this little duck
and then I'll pull out my my notebook
see I'm the queen of forgetting things
so that's why I have to write everything
down my brain can only obtain so much
knowledge young Jade I shall show you in
a minute Mews quickly go through yeah
because I know sometimes it can be
gremlins I don't want to stop in a
gremlin infested area I rather Zoot on
through okay we should be safe now
just checking checking come here where's
my notebook it won't be in that notebook
because that's a new one trusty old blue
all right I'm just gonna try and find it
quickly no you can't see what's in your
stop trying to sleep since Lucy why is
there a stink bug in my book look at
that this is the worst creature in the
entire world they're walking towards the
here we go in the groove of the book
that is a horrible stink bug get out of
my notebook I don't want to see you
because you try and fly into my mouth
and you taste absolutely terrible let me
turn it sorry there we go on the feather
now or flew away I'll SWAT you if you
come near me okay chameleons I've owned
lots of notes on comedians because for
so many amazing things to know about
them
whoops pages falling out let's go back
and have a look I wonder Jade I'm so
glad you are so happy maybe it's in the
brown book Jade so meaning and I you
know I should I should put them no I've
got any hair Rebecca I have it in here
but I want to get it right not the
proper one I thought is it I don't know
which notebook it is it might be in my
small little one of what everything else
here but I haven't got oh my goodness
right it seems as though Ralph is
winning he's joined the chameleon team
Jade I can't answer your question
because I'm hopeless today and my brain
can't concentrate so let's go to
Ralphie's found a chameleon thanks
Stella
and yes while I I must confess my
cameraman
Sebastiaan is the one that spotted that
so I'll contact credit for this one but
nonetheless is part of my team and yeah
thanks save yeah look at that a
beautiful chameleon flap necked and we
would really be able to see that flap
Nick if we had to go up there and
irritate him which is not exactly what I
want to do and then that lift the flap
on his neck would literally start to
change color and go every bright red or
yellow and you can actually tell if it's
male or female by the colour that he
changes do you see now I'm not sure if
Tyler has told you any of the folklore
around chameleons they are very
interested with the with the local
people and a lot of the different tribes
around Africa there is a lot of folklore
around these little creatures and a lot
of it is quite negative as well and
quite scared of a chameleon because of
its ability to be able to look in
completely different directions the two
different eyes so they say that the one
eye is looking into the future and the
other one looking into the past and if
you stare at a chameleon he will tell
you your future but it's normally not
very good so there is a quite a bit of
persecution of these little guys and
that's why I'm I if I can try to educate
the little locals or just try to show
them the good side of chameleons and
it's also a lot to do with snakes as
well and there's also quite a lot of
folklore around that as we sit still
here we are getting invaded by insects
so sorry if I do shift around a little
bit with my lot but look at that now I
know that Tyler was looking to find out
if they can see in color I'm almost 100%
sure that they can because that is half
the reason why they start to change to
the color of what they what they are
resting near with where they are and the
ones in the media the little Namaqua
chameleon
they um they use it the the colour
change a lot for thermoregulation so
they're very white when it's very hot in
the midday and in the early mornings
when you see them they're very dark and
that's all to do with like a heat
reflection or absorption as they are
ectothermic and some of the reptiles as
all of the reptiles are so they need to
take on the external heat and getting a
lot of insects yet might even help this
little chameleon invited everybody at
this chameleon might actually get a meal
because of us beetles of these little
dung beetles I think they are no not
whatever they are they definitely like
this lunch it's really strange are these
creatures fly towards the light
I was like why don't you fly towards the
Sun during the day and gun frezzle on on
the outer stratosphere just Jacky
he's a lot of them Wow but back to the
chameleon and these these chameleons are
arboreal meaning that they stay in the
trees not like those terrestrial ones
sittin bull' good question
chameleons kill the tails well they do
use it as a as a climbing tool and
obviously when it's when it's not in use
then it does make sense for them just to
curl it up a little bit now I don't know
if any of you have ever seen how the
chameleon moves with a very shaky motion
and they're very slow actually
especially when they're trying to move
from one place to another and it does
for me mimic either blowing leaves or
grass which is blowing in the wind and
so that's the kind of motion that they
get Wow getting attacked and Donna those
little feet of the chameleon are not
sticky I'm assuming that you that you're
referencing a geckos now it has also
been proven that geckos don't have sucky
feet they actually have a very fun
network of hairs and I think it was a
National Geographic documentary that I
watched that they they obviously put it
under a microscope and they could see
these hairs but they proved it by
putting a camellia gecko on a on a pane
of glass and they turned the pane of
glass around and so once it was sad you
know they're doing it on a vertical
point so they put the Gecko on it and
then they turn it 360 degrees and when
it's facing upside down virtually it
needs to shift to realign those hairs
which then go into all the little cracks
and and then seems like it's got
suctions but it actually doesn't it's
all a fine network of hair and these
chameleons don't have those fine network
of hair like the geckos have they've
literally just got two fingers that they
use as clamps and then they've got
little claws on them as well or little
and nails so then they'll use that to
assist in gripping on whatever they grab
on but very interesting so it seems that
we've put bug problems I think tail is
also getting bombarded Jason I believe
that chameleons are territorial and I
don't think that this chameleon wouldn't
allow another chameleon to come and join
him on his particular tree and as I said
I'm not quite sure if it's a male or
female but they will defend their
territory and it all comes with a lot of
color changing and you can actually see
their mood as well so it's not only for
camouflage as I said it can be used for
thermoregulation
and it can also it can also be used for
a particular mood so Cassandra I hope
that answers your question if they spot
another chameleon they might grow very
bright colors and the one with the
brightest colors and the biggest body he
will be the winner and try to deter the
other one now when I was with those
terrestrial chameleons we used to just
show people them on the ground and they
actually can be quite time we used to
catch the little tin of tin agree on it
Beto and hold it by the leg and move
close to the chameleons and once both of
those eyes lock in onto that beetle you
know that you're in business because he
walks forward a little bit and then he
will shoot his tongue out and take the
beetle right out of your fingers but you
need to hold it a little bit softly
because you can also damage their tongue
if you hold on to the leg and it's try
when it pulls back but incredible the
photos that we were able to get and
obviously there were a lot of Tina
Brianna beetles like we are getting
bombarded with at the moment but I don't
think that I'm going to try that right
now
because I don't know if it's this
chameleon will appreciate at e-mart
actually just be disturbed by my
presence so I've never tried it out with
these little guys but we used to find
the little five which included a lot of
other the other four little animals
which I have mentioned before but back
to our little animal here and he's gonna
be just sitting there waiting for
anything to come near by and then he
will also shoot his tongue out and catch
it and they can actually eat a lot of
beetles and those ones that were studied
I heard that they could eat up to over
twenty ten embryonic beetles or not and
those are the little pokey beetles the
ones that walk on the ground but I would
imagine here these are boreal flap
nichts chameleons feeding more on the on
the flying insects see those eyes he's
trying to look in on something and I'm
sure with the light yeah he's getting
quite interested in what's flying around
us at the moment I'm getting attacked as
well look at that very cool I like it
let's keep watching him because when
they do that it can very often mean he's
locked in on something
Lattin my lab yeah the chameleons do
make a little bit of vocalization but
it's it's mainly a hiss so they go if I
had to go close to him now which I'm not
going to demonstrate and they can also
do it to other chameleons changing color
into bright colors and hissing so yes
that's but it's not really a
vocalization then is it it's a passing
of wind but it is a noise that they make
so not particularly any kind of clicks
and things like the geckos do but they
do do hissing this chameleon should be
on board with us it was so there's so
many insects yeah you could eat is full
and that's wonderful
okay everybody I can't really stand
these beetles that much longer so I
think we're going to leave our little
chameleon alone and I think continue
along down the road as you can see there
I'm getting attacked so blind
mr. chameleon I hope you get some
wonderful dinner for you I think we're
going to move back to infrared now so
just get ready for that it's going to
change there we are okay
I've got to get these beetles off my
shirt luckily I've got glasses on so the
beetles that were trying to fly into my
eyes they hit a glass wall sorry for you
guys climbing in my hat and in my [ __ ]
anyway where's our lipids
now aha I'm not quite sure if animals
cry tears I know that elephants can they
sort of leak from the eyes a little bit
but it's not known whether they do that
out of sorrow or pain so it's quite you
know like dogs and cats they also have
this leaky substance coming out of the
eyes but it's mostly to try and assist
in keeping the eye clean an elephants
also when they when there's a lot of
pollen around as we saw a lot in the
Maasai Mara of the with the grass being
in flower then they also get this white
substance and and it's coming out of the
eyes but you know generally speaking
humans and the primates have a lot more
emotion than other than all the other
animals and that's probably one of the
reasons why they they they make better
decisions than humans do because they
don't act on emotion when we make
decisions based on emotion we generally
make the wrong one and it's when you can
cut all emotion art that you make the
decision based on what is needed to be
done rather than what you feel is you
know nicer it's it's it's a difficult
thing to to fathom but um I think that
that is the true reason why we make
silly decisions as humans anyway like
all these animals they living in the
moment and they're not too worried about
what is what has happened a year ago and
they're not too worried about what's
gonna happen in a year's time they are
living in that particular moment it's a
lot like kids like my kids at home and
in a an elder element relighting anybody
else's kids to animals but I'll relate
my kids to that of dogs and and that's
not in any derogatory way whatsoever
it's just that they live in the moment
and it's wonderful if you could if you
can do that every day just live in the
moment and not worry about what's going
to happen tomorrow and not worry about
what happened yesterday live in that
particular moment
but that is exactly correct we will not
be able to live in the moment if
everybody leaves their plastic around
and we drown in it so let's go off to
something about Earth Day
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yes everyone so don't forget about that
please we all need to do our little bit
to try and save our little beautiful
planet that we live on now I'd also like
to remind you that the dive live
Kickstarter campaign is on the go and if
you would like to contribute or get
involved in their wonderful initiative
of wild earth and safari lives
please go on to the website and I'd like
to thank all the wonderful guides that
were out today and all the one for
camels all the lovely people in FC most
of all all the viewers have a wonderful
evening
goodbye everybody and see you soon